we have breaking news from honduras
where the country's former president is
being sent to the u.s this morning to
face allegations of taking bribes from
drug traffickers juan orlando hernandez
has been in jail for the past two months
now the government of honduras has
decided it's time to extradite him to
the u.s jeff begays is in washington
jeff this is highly unusual it is good
morning we've learned that a dea plane
is scheduled to land at a honduran air
base this morning from there the former
president will be in u.s custody and
taken to new york city a senior u.s
official tells cbs news that hernandez
will face weapons and drug charges
hernandez was sworn in as president in
2014 and concluded his second term in
january of this year and then february
hernandez was arrested in honduras u.s
prosecutors in the southern district of
new york are expected to unseal an
indictment against him this week
in recent years they have accused
hernandez of funding his political rise
with profits from drug traffickers in
exchange for protecting their shipments
hernandez denies any wrongdoing it is
extremely rare for an ex-president and
ex-head of state to be extradited former
panamanian president manuel noriega you
remember was captured by u.s forces in
office in 1990 and later sentenced to
prison on drug trafficking and
racketeering charges the arrest of
hernandez comes during a period where
over the past 20 years the u.s has
provided hundreds of millions of dollars
in humanitarian aid to honduras a
country whose residents have been
fleeing in large numbers to the u.s
border do in part
this type of alleged corruption yale
got it jeff thank you very much